it's been a desperate homecoming for
miguel cetto
he was deported from the u.s in
september after two years of working
illegally in miami
now he's back in his village chepyun in
the guatemalan highlands to find the
harvest has failed
20 000 guatemalans have been deported
from the u.s this year
according to the country's migration
institute and they're coming back to
find that the conditions that they fled
are now even worse the economy is
projected to contract
due to the pandemic and experts say the
country's also increasingly affected by
climate change
some of its regions are part of a dry
belt spreading throughout central
america
and guatemala has also just been
devastated by two november hurricanes
they destroyed the crops in miguel's
village and now food is scarce
amidst those natural disasters many of
those deported are also struggling
to pay off debt
that's because people smugglers often
charge migrants ten thousand dollars or
more
to take them north the idea is they'll
pay it back gradually once working in
the states
but it's a gamble and those that are
kicked out have to pay the money anyway
as the parents of miguel and his cousin
who was caught with him
are now discovering me
when my son arrived i felt glad that we
still have this debt to pay
and we're suffering it's seven thousand
seven hundred dollars
and i'm trying to sell a bit of land to
pay it as a father i want to help my son
but instead of getting ahead we only get
poorer
we're healthy but in our hearts we have
that pain
what can we do where can we go now we
have nobody to support us in the u.s
the guatemalan president has recently
said the answer to the problem
is to create prosperity in communities
like shepard so that people don't have
to leave in the first place
the incoming biden administration has
pledged to spend
four billion dollars on central america
to do just that
but it's tough to make sure the money
gets to where it's needed
past efforts show that it won't be a
silver bullet to stop migration
john holman al jazeera